why plans on Saturday - I'm having
dinner with my parents so you don't even
like your parents
you call them smiley morons and hug
freaks plans our plans I'm a badass not
an anarchist you wanted to see me sir I
understand you stopped by the patrol
offices morning briefing yeah officer
deetmore helped me out with my crime
scene so I gave him a little thank-you
present hey deetmore
you're gonna bag evidence like a
five-year-old you should have the proper
tools it's my first police kit the
walkie talkie blows bubbles hope you can
handle it he mislabeled the weapon like
an idiot and it almost got filed with
the wrong case he could have one months
of work you humiliated officer deetmore
in front of his peers he submitted an
official complaint against you did he
fill it on crayon
no but he did use a green pen which
seems crazy to me the good news is if
you go down there and apologize you'll
let the whole thing go fine I'm great at
apologizing I'm a very sweet person
out of my way chunk momento what's up
what's up with you I need you to sign
this report okay I'll sign your report
what the hell
careful being still wet maybe this'll
help okay they got to knock that off
loosen up Sarge somewhere love baby
it's March man shut up I see the color
blue and yellow and I see the letter L R
s twe
and B so basically everyone's first
eight guess is in hangman Thank You
Carlene your entire life is garbage so
of all the candidates that you interview
today who do you think I should hire
well the interviews got a little off
track but I'd go with Simon Walker
computer science degree work for the
Board of Ed for ten years no way he
yelled at me when I asked him the same
question about Jay Z three times in a
row what does that matter because
whoever takes this IT job is gonna have
to deal with Hitchcock asking how to log
into his email every single day forever
how do you think professor short fuse is
going to handle that fine
what about this guy no he was scared of
everything do you remember Rosa's
reaction last time the printer jammed
[Music]
pay for that okay all right no problem
okay all right yeah my babysitter's busy
the night of Boyle's wedding she's gonna
be in her high school talent show which
he's gonna lose unless her talent is
leaving potato chip crumbs all over
Terry's couch
wait Boyle set a date already hey he
gave up saved two days yesterday he
ain't give you one I mean he's been
avoiding me you didn't invite me to his
wedding and he's scared like a little
[ __ ] well maybe Vivian was
uncomfortable with you coming but boy I
was in love with you until a few weeks
ago oh don't be angry I'm not angry I
think it's funny officer deetmore came
down here to say I'm sorry oh good go
ahead no that was it I did it I said I'm
sorry
hey I said it again now got one in the
bank so I can do whatever I want to you
what are you even sorry for come on man
I said the words I paused afterwards I
even averted my gaze to make you feel
like the Alpha yeah but you didn't mean
it I'd like you to apologize like you
mean it
fine I'm sorry you screwed up my case
I'm sorry you're a terrible cop I'm
sorry for your goat face and your rodent
brain and your weird goose body and then
all of that I hope you feel better
Peralta what the hell where were you I
got eliminated excuse me officer yes
sweetheart sweetheart seriously Hank is
how you talk to women who come in here
Jimmy jabs I didn't make a pass one
person all right Gina
we have to act soon that cold medicine
Diaz chugged it was the ninth Rowsey
kind she's all over the place hey guess
what I got a new lead that's my firm
about this is drug dealer on State
Street
hello no there's no Michael here you're
the wrong number goodbye I'm Michael
that's a dumb name but it's yours and
you should be proud of it because you
are the greatest detective I've ever
known
no doy yes no doy
is my file she so hopped up on that
stuff her brains gonna blow I'm gonna
interrogate the purse you keep the ass
occupied I don't want to get near her
germ face permission to lock her in a
distant room no just distract her yes
that is what I will do gotta tell you
something is a secret okay everything
okay with yes yeah she fell asleep five
minutes after I locked her in and she
hasn't moved in the past ten hours she
talks in her sleep rip your damn head
off grandma Oh ter-bear what if she
sleeps forever you look great girl I
gotta get out of here bye better not run
because I will catch you after I'm done
crushing that perp you are next
I already interrogated the perp for you
what I got him a name his giggle Pig
supplier it's all good now go home and
get better I could have done it myself
no you couldn't no you literally have
been in a coma since yesterday now I
know you like to act like you don't need
any help but we all do I ask five dudes
to spot me when I'm doing my squats
Terry paid me $20 to lock you up no I
did not but I took that cheddar and I
made you this special Rosa's gonna make
this called her [ __ ] care package now's
the time will you say thank you for all
your help thank you for all your help
hey is that a smile I see possibly my
immune system is too weak to fight off
my small muscles
that's a pee-eww or portable ultrasonic
weapon it emits a focused beam of sound
which can disorient and even
incapacitate a purple so shoot sound mmm
is this a trigger yes but you want to be
careful with that
I thought it would be louder it's highly
directional pointed at you you'd be in
incredible pain right now you not the
answer pretty cool I only had Arlo for a
day and a half but if anything happened
to him I would kill everyone in this
room and then myself very violent eulogy
I like it just let those guys continue
to terrorize Brooklyn until I built up
to the nerve to ask out a girl you're a
good cop do not beat yourself up about
that I'm not a good cop I'm an amazing
cop and I'll never forgive myself the
case is over Amy and majors are on their
way to the keychain right now it's too
late
has she done the double tuck yet when
Amy really likes the guy she gets
nervous and tucks her hair behind both
ears at the same time well I can never
unsee that but no she has not done that
yet then there's still time get in there
and bust up her date show her you care
ruin her night you really have a unique
take on love hey deetmore I'm sorry for
making fun of you in front of everybody
and also for making fun of you behind
your back didn't know you did that but
thank you for the apology
I'm not done also I'm sorry for making
fun of you during my book club those
people don't even know you that was
uncool also I'm sorry it's okay I get it
no also I'm sorry that I didn't take the
time to show you how to fix your mistake
come on we can go over to upstairs
Thanks it'll be great
Oh one more sorry you're about to see a
drawing I did of you in the elevator
just remember I was really pissed to you
at the time
yes look what I found in Hitchcock and
Scully's trashcan ice cream spoon
[ __ ] you Hungry Hungry Hippos ate my
ice cream
why was this in your trash and who
throws away a spoon it's the easiest
utensil to clean I don't even think it's
ice cream it's probably medicine you
know I'm on lots of medicines Rosa I'm
sick all over this is ice cream and I'm
gonna prove it
Sarge no it's been in their mouths what
well I guess your little investigations
hit a dead end
I'll be back till much not a problem I
hate moving let it go
you